[Music]
this pretty lady's name is astrix and
this is her son nate
they are northern white-cheeked gibbons
their species is critically endangered
only about a thousand of them are left
in the world
[Music]
these gibbons are found in vietnam and
laos
they were also once found in southern
china but are thought to be extinct
there due to logging of the gibbon's
habitat
asterix and nate mainly eat fruit but
asterix has a sweet tooth for dandelions
infants are pale at birth and turn black
as they age
female gibbons will change color again
as they near sexual maturity becoming
golden or a deep red males remain black
[Music]
gibbons are known as small apes because
of their slight stature
these primates have long arms which are
much longer than their legs
and they are muscular with strong thighs
and shoulders to help them swing through
trees
the speed and agility of this species
has earned them the reputation as the
trapeze artists of the animal kingdom
this is the northern white cheeked
gibbon
[Music]
you